[Music]
hi everyone how's it going welcome to
the premiere of grave hoppers it's 2
p.m. Pacific here on Thursday in San
Francisco I'm Mike my Hardy here with
Rob handler hey and we've been planning
the show for a while what originally
started as like this huge this huge like
edited thing we were like why don't we
live stream this just shoot you know
give people glimpse of how the sausage
is made so to speak so this is Grave
hoppers the show where we put perma
deaths in every game that's right do you
want the graveyard right now so let me
explain so you can see our fantastic
pixelated characters they're so cute we
are putting permadeath in every game so
Rob for an hour every week Rob and I
will be playing these games here Far Cry
fives what we're starting with so today
Robin Robin play for an hour I'll be
hosting checking out chat if he dies at
any point in any fashion we are moving
on to doom 2016 that's right at which at
which point I will play and he will
surely die within the first few moments
and we'll jump right into halo combat
Evolved I'm legendary I'll be playing
that yeah whatever uh but we also if he
survives the whole hour today we will
continue from that save file in Far Cry
5 next week Thursday at 2 so yeah we
just are gonna see how far we get in
each of these games I don't know you
think we could beat any of these Far Cry
5 might for crafting to be far cry 5 I
don't think so so that's the graveyard
will and then you want to bring it back
up really quick again yeah you could see
the time we're gonna record the time
that we died at after playing so right
yeah we'll put a little gravestone next
to it so you can really get it get a
taste of how long and the pain that was
that was happening during that play that
makes any sense sure why not yeah Bob
Jones if we do go through all these
games in one episode then we'll just
we'll find other games to play
but right now also this list is subject
to change that's right so if you think
of a game that would work really well
with this those are they're not set in
stone but they're kind of the ones we
really want to do we thought I'm a few
more this week after we like already
kind of decided on those but yeah that's
the gist of the show
we will be doing this every Thursday
whenever possible at 2 p.m. Pacific here
from GameSpot it'll be me and Rob yes
should we get on with it let's jump in
so ok so it is 207 I just want to show
so we were playing Rio seven if you got
to survive till 307 in Far Cry 5 ok so
yeah we want to make sure that we know
exactly when we're starting this yes I
just wanted to show everyone here that
for sure we are playing on the hardest
difficulty yep in fact right so I took
the liberty of skipping all the dumb
tutorials of this game which you are
unskipable and it's like 15 minutes
worth of cutscenes yeah cut cut scenes
are the antithesis of what we want to do
with this show we want to make it fun to
watch so if there is a game up ahead we
might skip around to the amount of the
meat of it which is right here when you
open up this trap door and venture forth
into the world okay you know I'm gonna
put a timer for one hour since you just
started to a counter and we'll tally
that up why as opposed to huh
forget it no look it's got its countdown
an hour it's gonna be like 308 308 p.m.
today Pacific okay so I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be playing what you're on the hard
to put them on the hardest okay so this
is Dutchess Island this is still kind of
tutorial
esque it just kind of shows you the gist
of the entire game you have the case 81
meant to try out for ya keep in mind
games you might want to suggest a few
sir I'm surprised how much of this game
is unskipable like right here
okay yeah people want to start pools for
how long they think Rob will survive
that works
I can't you can you from gameplay down a
tiny bit you might I definitely know I
don't Alice away from you yeah that's
fine
interact with chat if I need to just
don't distract me yeah we got chat up
well with twitch chat up we're streaming
to twitch um should me yeah cool I got
twitch YouTube GameSpot chats up so feel
free to yeah Rob a little more game
everyone Ryan Schubert is I agree I
think you're stalling Rob not just
kidding
so you die right here we go to doom
don't say that this is gonna get pretty
tense what's his name Maury scared what
thanks for saving my life we're on the
hardest difficulty Michael hi I'm sorry
keep going yeah we run the hardest hard
Ryan thinks a wild bear is gonna do you
in so I I was training yesterday and
that's exactly how I died two swipes of
a wild bear alright let's get moving so
I'm gonna be playing very reserved like
uh oh yeah we're not we're not trying to
like do a highlight reel kind of thing
we're trying to survive you know what is
the name of this difficulty hard it's
just called hard for those of you
naysayers okay yeah so Rob imagine if in
future games developers include a grave
hoppers difficulty oh that's so cool
that'd be so neat seems like there's a
lot of people here it's a good time in
the day to do this it's like right at
that peak awake time before the
afternoon low but after lunch has made
you fall asleep at your desk yes I have
coffee tea and crack yeah that's a good
way to put it
tell me ramen apologize my brush with
that uh one heart playthrough I guess
yeah
this difficulty is one hard difficulty
I'd say but God of War Bob Jones mention
God of War so we were thinking god of
war but then whoa and there's so much
story and narrative in that yeah we
played through it and it's some of the
sections are like puzzle II and I'm sure
it'd be a fun long play maybe if people
are really invested but we didn't want
to like necessarily do that early on in
this series
yeah like it it is very dependent on the
type of game like some games just don't
really work as well as we think so what
is your approach or how do you play this
game if you like to do outposts er well
I don't know man so I was thinking about
this too like what what exactly should
we be achieving in this game like okay
um I think the first thing you have to
you have to liberate this island first
right for sure but the the thing I was
thinking well first off I'm playing very
stealth like like a cat
I got ninja I think that's the only way
to really do it as far as taking down an
outpost
you cannot go guns blazing
but I was thinking about like the perk
system in this yeah we really want to
survive right like yeah well you also
like oh I don't even have to get deals
tutorial okay in order to get experience
you're probably gonna have to actually I
mean you're gonna have to get into
combat so that's nice it's not like
we're just gonna launder the road I mean
even in this game even if you just do
wander around some you'll run into
something oh for sure like a bear could
come out of there yeah oh yeah
one more time seems like a lot of big
influx of people have joined since we
started this is great hoppers the show
where we put permadeath in every game so
we've got nine games on this list I'll
pull up really quick Robert you do
anything important no which so this is
the list these are the this is tentative
this is subject to change these are the
games right here you can see Robins
playing Far Cry 5 on hard on the ps4 we
did ps4 as opposed to PC because a bunch
of the games that we have loaded up are
on this ps4 we're gonna record how long
you survives if he survives until 308
p.m. Pacific today he will continue far
cry 5 and you know we're yeah and then
the next week will pick up where I left
off and we'll keep going but if you were
to die right now I would pick up the
controller and start playing doom this
way on the Hard difficulty depending on
the game will switch difficulties a
little bit because doom on the hardest
yeah Miami that would oh that would be
so quick like there are some games you
just wouldn't do it like Celeste or like
or like hollow Knight even we are
original like when we so this show has
been works for a while when we were
doing like a pilots for the staff to
check out and give us feedback we did
super meatboy and we did spelunky and it
was a lot of stuff that ended very
quickly so we thought it was it would be
more fun if it was tense like kind of
games where you could actually have a
fighting chance for longer than five
minutes yeah are you just gonna try to
beef your dude up are you gonna go
stealth err that's yeah once we see the
perks who he saw we're gonna have to
take a look at the perks I mean like
there's the thing is I was looking at it
just the other day like there's health
but it takes six perk points so that's
kind of ways away but then there's like
things that are essential like a
parachute you never know if I fall off a
cliff or something you know
I just don't want you to make noise nope
nice gotta pick my arrow back up where
are you boy do you not pick him up
automatically I thought you maybe I did
you just got them did you would you make
your character look like I guess we'll
see him I didn't care he's blond with
like a ugly like rat tail nice just like
in real life as you say for the realism
clear come on are you close to that no
it is interesting now like in the in the
copilot seat you do get the jitters as
well I'm a [ __ ] what's the appropriate
term I'm tensed up yeah for sure
[Music]
yeah Bob Jones that's that's also
something we're paying attention to new
games that come out that might fit well
I don't know what's down the road um
what's next
octopus comes out tomorrow that'd be
kind of boring I think if you're not it
don't I love that game but it might not
be fun to watch that yeah Michael ha and
that's kind of what I was going for the
butt stuff oh yeah dude getting a
companion would be helpful like even if
they're dumb they could just distract
guards okay I mean I'm into this like
meat shield Survival Plan don't you
[Laughter]
don't shoot I swear I'm fine I've got
six kids
oh oh yo yo get in the fight
like they could have separated those
button dude give him a rocket launcher
no it's Luke Smith
it's Luke Smith dude he's so dumb I told
him to like stay put he goes okay I'm
going in no don't get drilled by a
slow-rolling he's gonna be the death of
me I still got stalks yeah he's gonna
throw a grenade at some point yeah what
else fish it what comes out I mean
there's a lock in our Red Dead
Redemption - I don't know if that would
fit - well that's - story-driven I think
yeah I mean we'll play the games before
we decide to put him in here alien
isolation is one that we have on here
that really makes me sweat that's that's
gonna suck ya falling damage dude that
sells would go way through quickly I
love that go so much you'll just slid
down the cliff screaming hey I'm here
like what's five guys I know Luke Smith
Shh anybody spotted okay um is that all
of them no more
spider-man might be good I don't even
know I played that at all yet gosh I
[ __ ]
yeah prey prey on survival hard
difficulty be great that's a bold shot
you are you're going for those long
distance shots
we stopped oh well let's you're flying
this is the first time do you have an
assault rifle no I only have a pistol
something oh no now rat's butt oh you
can hold 13 oh Jesus
Oh Luke Luke with his first kill nice
alright let's go pick up those arrows
you've proven your worth shadow the tomb
Raider's come out spider-man I feel I
mean you could do like like maybe
battlefield single-player not Call of
Duty yeah oh they have those not calling
area they're in well yeah survival a
survival difficulty would be fun state
of decay - yeah I like that game I
realize most people didn't like this
state okay would be boring I think so
yeah that's another thing the reason we
decided to do live stream is because
when we originally trying this out and
piloting it we found that we were if we
got bored instead of trying to survive
we would just like force these dumb
situations but now that we're trying to
survive the hour we have an objective
and encourages us to stay alive yeah so
what do you what do you out of curiosity
alright you are about we started like 12
12 minutes in sick 13 minutes
I think I might get to the our having
played yesterday yeah you're practicing
but I definitely like there are times
just when you slip like again if
everyone or anyone who knows this game
like you'll be focused on like a bunch
of Peggy's and then a bear will come out
of the woods and bite your head off yeah
okay where am I going
I did that what are those blue marks are
those other outposts I'm just supposed
to do now an outpost but did you turn
the HUD off a little bit yeah I did I
turn it on no I don't I don't mind I
just I was curious I didn't Bioshock
will be good yeah eventually it tells no
where to go I know that much oh I'll
find because now it's the outpost okay I
got to find smokes just probably this
way Luke's just ripping up long
days gone would work that's in February
same day as crackdown three Metro Exodus
and anthem Metro eggs this would be
fantastic I feel like this game looks so
good yeah it's not a pro yeah oh okay
here we go
how many arrows do you have I don't know
six let's hope there's six guys so your
objective right now is just to clear all
the outpost on the island it's it's
giving noise this one yeah just this
like it's still kinda toriel it's just
like showing the taste not even be worth
clearing the other ones if there are
others just to get the experience for
the perks that's what I was thinking too
cuz I think oh my god any off to the
right should probably get out before I
fall for good that's why I really hope I
don't die like that I have been real
dumb just let the
like what
Oh is he one of the prophets no no no
Luke Luke can get you right Luke if you
wait can Luke does that count
no okay Luke got you right does that
count I don't know it doesn't count I
think that counts yeah I mean like cuz
we can't I - right yeah he can't I - I
don't know I sit that's like a roommate
and think of we didn't think of that
does that count
I need a pole does that count is Robin
out or we'll move on or can they revive
him like he technically you played by
the rules right he revived you you got
to get a game over screen that's what
we're trying I'm fine I'm fine with that
that'll what little Jesus all right
there's two there's two that say yeah
you could be revived why'd you go into
that building I don't know I did it
yesterday went fine now you don't you
can't revive like yeah you didn't die
like technically yeah okay all right
well overall he revived you I wonder if
we I wanted to make it more tension
should get rid of ya you didn't die okay
cool revive can't forgot I forgot that
could happen okay game over screen will
end it but in the interest of keeping
more tense do you want to get rid of
companions from here on out yeah that's
funny how did you just what are you just
tell him to go away yeah I can do that
okay what about boomer no he can drive
you yeah all right no more companions
all right no I so that was that was a
freebie in a way I guess ya know people
people right you didn't you didn't die
technically I didn't die yeah cuz they
revive you they revived you there's no
there's no question about it okay but to
make it more tense from here on out we
will ask you companions you went right
in there you took an arrow to the back
of the skull and as I hey what's up did
I not make contact with you shot him in
the back of the head I shot in the back
of the head
this game sucks yeah Irish curse we
agree we're gonna keep companions off
now companions are off Luke Smith is out
of the picture which sucks cuz I love
Luke has done as he is god I screamed
yeah sorry alright no there's like the
one tower owned on the head I saw him in
the back office I was like oh that
explains why you body didn't okay I also
don't want to fall off this yeah you
don't know wingsuit everything I have
nothing
yeah the wind like sways you and you're
high up in this game and forgotten I
don't like Heights to begin with I
really like when the mist clears though
yeah we have to watch a really dumb
animation or not emissions cutscene
Oh God all right case anybody has joined
in the last 20 minutes this is great
hoppers you sure we put permadeath in
every game so as soon as Rob officially
dies in farcry we will move on to the
next game but a few survives for an hour
until 308 p.m. Pacific we will continue
with that save file next week so we had
a very very close call about as close as
you can get and then our companion
revived us but we told them to go away
so now what are we gonna do and you
wanted to go right to Jacobs they'll be
tough right are you gonna go to G I mean
John I'm gonna go here okay I think make
sense
what am I supposed to be doing here and
we've got a few games I'll pull the list
up very fast you think you can keep
playing this is a list right here if
you're just joining you see Far Cry 5
right here Dhoom 2016 I'm gonna be
playing that if Rob dies today or at any
point and then we will play I'll take
over and we'll play until 308 p.m. today
because that's when we started 208 and
yeah we're just if you die in any of
these games you move on to the next one
there's nine games nine lives
and again that list is subject to change
but yeah I like games perma death so we
figured why not put them put it into
everything I really can't wait to see
what stupid way he's gonna die I'm not
gonna die
you got closed loop this game this game
is very uh there's a lot of potential
for dumb deaths in this game ever watch
this scene doing this is dude skip right
no you can't skip any cutscenes it's so
abrasive what cutscene is it it's John
seed and he's it's like he's like
infomercial oh yeah
man I was really upset when that
happened I really wanted to get off this
island at least yeah Luke save you yeah
the touchpad doesn't do anything like I
trust I trust you but okay I'm falling
off the top of this tower [ __ ] beard
yeah he's got dumb beard also he's got a
belt round his neck Hines wonder what
he's in do you get a haircut Dead Rising
to be good the forest would be pretty
good yeah I mean there's boring there's
a few games I could think of like
survival deaths sometimes are very slow
burns and not exciting is the only
problem
yeah the forest would be pretty
uneventful until that death
there she is the deputy right yes I am a
sinner it's not I don't think it's a
belt around his neck I think that's the
the collar oh it does look like a belt
yeah I mean it's it's a belt collar
collar belt you don't have to do
anything I'll come for you creepy to
Eden's gate
okay cool shut up sign up now here we go
okay so I'm gonna go miss the zipline
when you jump off us I really want to
get down from here okay so a plan of
action here I'm gonna go to boomer I
guess well keep mine we're not gonna be
able to use them yeah I know I don't
know what else I should be doing you
work the quest experience yeah it's a
quest so let's do it like I should stick
to quests and maybe some outposts but I
feel like out posed to be risky what
games reward you for not dying the souls
games in general we have Dark Souls
remastered on the list
we played blood-borne at some point we
picked res evil for specifically because
of its very intuitive dynamic difficulty
the longer you serve I have the heart of
the game gets so that's kind of opposite
but I still love that game I think I
could beat resonable for it without
dying I definitely can I think I've done
it before
but on which difficulty is the question
alright three arrows F yeah did the
boats people can like in this game
people notice you right there there's
people there yeah I died to them before
not today
today someone said that a I won't kill
you in the game this game is tough this
you die easier in this game more easily
in this game than a 3 4 etc alright how
are you
use knife that dude what happened oh
dress swap weapon so should I keep the
bows damn that would be a good perk to
have the extra primary weapons I know
right
I don't know I really really got scared
when they were rushing at you and all
you had was the bow this is the second I
fire a gun they're all gonna come after
me yeah you died say Rock go with the
bow right now yeah he's on board
oh okay so you state you stick to the
woods you run the higher chance of
running into animals you stick to the
road you run the higher chance of
running into peggy's I think I still
stick to the woods I can I can only I
could outrun a bear yeah I think in this
game you know sounds like a big cat no
you make it did you lose him don't turn
around just keep running no you're not
gonna win this fight with the things you
get oh you've c4 dude did you you almost
killed yourself get on that get on that
[Music]
that was you almost blew yourself up -
yeah that was a cool move wasn't it
alright do you survive so the wilderness
is definitely a viable option like I was
just don't go back now he's out here I
was right that was a cougar for sure
well just just to prove my point about
the woods being dangerous your screen
just flashes red oh thanks for warning
I'll write that down oh you know is all
around here is that for some experience
right what is that that's a turkey it'll
attack but those things are vicious
pretty sure there's a sorry about people
wearing headphones oh yeah sorry owned
to happen here we go this one maybe just
merchant yeah sorry I think I just asked
this but did you unlock perks yet or no
yes I did do you have experience that's
fine
so this is what I'm talking about like
we don't have any yeah six like I should
probably invest in like a parachute just
in case
but I don't know what's more filling at
how you instinctually open up the pause
menu I yeah people do that they made it
well you don't have any points yet but I
guess we'll cross that bridge when we
come to it so I guess the companion
thing might as well be not even there oh
look it's Jacob seed in the chat
should I just waiting for it should I
just save it or should I go prepare you
don't have a point that's what I'm
saying oh I thought I did no no nope
nope why would you wear orange warning
hunting gear in this kind of Matt
whatever I'm gonna get ammo Rockman
bionics we are putting permit earth in
every game as you can see we almost just
died my heart hurts you're about like
exactly half hour into this episode 12
really I could have sworn it was an L oh
no no we finished was that a bad choice
how'd you do I bought a bunch of ammo no
like arrows so yeah yeah you're pretty
well-equipped as long as you don't like
run into a base like you did earlier or
like get attacked by a cougar well
that's just unavoidable but going into
that cabin earlier was uh yeah I am too
I just I'm hiding it I'm always what no
honestly I'm always sweating in this
room because it's really hot but no
sorry Rockman bionics if we die super
early keep playing I'm just gonna bring
up real quick this is the list of games
we're gonna move right on to the next
game so if we die three times within the
hour we will play three games back to
the game sorry I just shown him soon
quick yeah
thank you Michael hi Emma's in our chat
whoa we're gonna alternate Rob's playing
Rob is gonna keep playing far cry until
he dies that could be six weeks it could
be six more minutes go stand next that's
great pretend you're a scarecrow all
right let's check out what we got
fallout four surviving what keeps
getting brought up that'd be a good one
it would you can die very fast if you go
up against the wrong super mutants
and that's a game where we wouldn't but
I don't think we should also need to be
like starting from the beginning of
these games you know you could start at
any point like any save if there's like
character creation of lengthy intro we
will do our homework before we go live
like you did for this
unfortunately this game doesn't let you
skip cutscenes go into this Jacob seed
cool idea for a live stream I'm waiting
I'm waiting for you guys to get to my
area than that do your you got a lot of
concealment in this route you chose like
an idea you're in an open field oh I see
I see I hope that thing doesn't come for
you know it's it's boomer oh oh you're a
tray race gotcha and yeah for those who
just joined we got saved by a companion
earlier so we figured this we would stop
using companions Dan I love boomer but
yeah I think it's the right choice to
Tim he kind of took care of that himself
oh yeah hee hee things we can't I said I
mean for the experience I'd say recruit
him but then let him go I think I have
to in order to complete the mission
right yeah oh I've never seen him do
that before that's really sad that is
Jacob Boca Chica goon sorry hey nice to
meet you I'll take care of you just
kidding you have to go hey baby hey baby
alright so now he's following you Oh get
rid of him man they're keeping pulling
up you gotta get rid of him he's not I
don't think he's yes no he's not he's no
what on a sign there you go dammit
you [ __ ] cheater I know your game no
I was not trying there's people rolling
up in trucks right yeah I think so let's
just use these proximities because I'm
really good with them
is that what they are not see for single
bad dude you just shot you do Jesus okay
are they chasing you still there in a
car
you want to go back and clear them out
er I don't know I can't I can't live my
life like a Wallace I got it I mean so
get there
oh [ __ ] out who sees you that guy suck
this dick that was good more of a space
between those phrases
[Laughter]
dude it's a [ __ ] bear comes up behind
you right now
bone arrows are not a good idea
Malta Christ yeah you can cover your
tracks with fire if you really don't
want them chasing you
oh he's dead yeah you better get on that
phone yeah but the house is kind of
engulfed in flames
stop moving I wouldn't even yeah oh he's
getting any going get whatever you want
yet oh oh nope
you're done for bro no you gonna use
that truck Oh we'll find out whatever oh
there's a ATV over there again oh here's
a nice truck
what is that exclamation point to the R
what is that sidequest thing showing up
this way sorry boomer oh yeah well you
know I wouldn't do that you get
experience for liberating right you know
did you didn't unlock a perk point that
you he's blinking a lot
the other thing we can do is challenges
that's how you get perks so like if I
stick to some of these let's see here
arrow kills I killed one person with an
arrow are you kidding me yeah great well
let's change that grenade kills that's
one Molotov oh I could probably do a
couple oh oh I could do this how you do
these two easy easy
where you going looks like my friend
tanner we can liberate them they don't
automatically recruit though so we can
get the experience for liberating them
can I do this outpost yeah is it close
by yeah oh it's right across the road
that's the other side of the street oh
this is this is the one there's a when
you liberate it there's a person at the
outpost that gives you a side quest to
go kill a couple bears yeah so I would
yeah sure
at least go liberate it I'd say that's
right question oh you can blow up the
silo if you want
I'm scared driving this car my infinite
films okay
oh my Shire in the side of the head
there's two you could try to get some
perk points we kill them of the
proximity thing oh that's a grenade this
thing is gonna blow up that silo if you
two birds with one c4 that should've
given you two perk points right if that
was the complete of the challenge for
room no I think I had one just go
fishing the rest of the game time just
go to perks no oh you I need one more
I'll be cool all right where's my car
he's going right up the middle I mean
should I stuff this then probably to you
I don't know if Bears are gonna be here
before the quest or what
just an FYI I did this exact route late
yesterday when I was doing my my
training and I died to a bear so let's
see if I can survive this yeah get the
high ground let's check out the prim
okay all right guys got cross there's a
guy there's a bear oh you could lend
that bear go in the cage
let him thrash a few dudes I like the
way you think is there anybody up top
isn't that no no actually I should go
for this guy right this us livestreams
great for my anxiety problems nice
I should just be able to do this
yep hi everyone this is my friend Bear
this is Bear Grylls
what is that bear made oh yes that's oh
he just killed someone you didn't mark
look at this guy
oh look at this guy Oh mauled him get up
bear yeah what happened like two more I
think about that where's he going come
get this guy oh he killed up hostage
maybe freedom well there's the bear
freedom I mean I guess I it's a tie
freedom it gave you the credit for it
what do you why the flash black I don't
know but it scared
sweet undetected nice is that bear still
gonna be there probably
here we go come on in everybody
yeah soundtrack this game forget how
much I liked it nice transition fire
transition all the way alright how much
you have 20 minutes left uh yeah about
20 minutes little more all right pork
points at all now wait this is bear
still here
[Music]
probably some ammo we all wait for this
battle start talking we're about 40
minutes in mares yeah I don't know you
need to like line their cave with from
proximity mines I don't think you have
anything else that could kill them
should I swap my weapon to four bears
you might as well I guess an arrow who's
not gonna be able to thing it'll take
like seven arrows on this difficulty if
not more like I would say shotgun but if
you're that close you're pretty much
done I would say I saw rifle I don't
want I want to keep some distance all
right what's load there's got 20 minutes
left
19 if you survive for anybody joining if
Rob survives the next 90 minutes until
the end of the hour until 308 p.m.
Pacific we continue with this save file
next week at the same time if he were to
die with five minutes left I would play
five minutes of doom and then we would
pick up with doom this is going really
well
mm-hmm oh it's loading I didn't see that
I guess I could bring up no why cancel
out all right body armor oh I should do
that
yeah well Oh with weapon fire only but
still it'd be good for down the road in
case of bears killing me with the a kay
let's see don't have anything this is
hard
Jake on youtubes hardest difficulty
available right now
6000 the DLC weapons uh I probably say
avoid those I still have to buy him
which is a little ironic I mean I should
go with this and get rid of this
you think you think some camo will help
me out okay look at this dude on YouTube
trying to get you killed jump off a
cliff you start with the wingsuit in
this game Oh get out of here
should I get ammo for what you have what
you get the m4 thing I have that's why
you can't buy these yet this is dynamite
this is gonna go I don't know you don't
have you can't buy those here's them I
can't buy him until I get a perk all
right you wanna go but you do have I
thought you got perk points after that
Oh display no nevermind great okay yeah
you have to first scatter it out right
can I look around here maybe it's just
some good in here yeah there's probably
like a lot of times there's oh there's a
prepper stash thing I don't know if it's
a prepper stash but it is a what where
things like a key it's like I was locked
storage room over there Oh over here
someone said he's right you jump off you
have a wingsuit get out of here
they are messing with us right you don't
have a wingsuit yet no you have to
unlock it okay
forgot where the key was it's on the
outside right or there's a note back by
the door
market stall where's this market stall
toward the front maybe come on there's
ammo explosives
oh good rocket launcher ammo I don't
know where a market stall would be yeah
I'm feeling there's absolutely nothing
in here you also just became the size of
a possum yeah I guess just go for the
for the Bears there's three bears I can
do this
does he have anything useful over here
bliss ooh yeah let them do some damage
oh she's dead yeah someone said you
grabbed nitro tonight rose a few seconds
ago did you what someone said you
grabbed some remote explosives and
didn't notice you did oh I did nice
thank you
time is sleep all right that's one bliss
does not help
there's gonna be another one right there
guess that's our guy I mean you could go
for a perk point no no I cancel that you
could go for the pork one with the
remote well does it count as a kill
though yeah uh-oh like as opposed to
killing a human yeah I think so
I always get a shot Jesus that works
that's too you know the last ones in
this case maybe it didn't count then
still worth using though should I save
it I would recommend just putting it
outside the cave and then luring it out
and blowing it up
I mean two for the prayer pointer oh I
didn't know that was for the Bearskin oh
you're right
can you use an ease right now I mean I
should get parachute might be helpful if
you're falling off a tall cliff yeah I'm
not getting I know you're right that's
why I mean I went for that first part me
really wants this but that's a while
away I feel like we should just do this
yeah yeah you never know if like the
floor is gonna give out on a high-rise
oh what happened oh oh oh wait you have
another point to spend Oh
breathing underwater or more ammo which
is handgun in melee weapons save it yeah
it's a alright so I throw it you'll die
in this cave alright so I throw it like
right here and then lure him out and
then wait for him to come out of the
cave
the idea of luring them out I don't like
so much food why fate I do yeah
alright we got ourselves a little bit of
a plan here just please give yourself
enough distant yeah oh you maybe you
didn't trigger him yet what if I attract
a different animal then we'd have
ourselves a little situation it's good
real brouhaha he not in there yet he's
gotta be in there how is he not in there
maybe he hasn't like maybe since it's a
quest related you haven't triggered it
yet I don't like this at all now I'm all
hi you tough did you get him you were on
the perfect edge of that blast zone
sorry we're ripping people's ears out
dude he was so fast Jesus Christ those
yeah is this one of those games where
the developers actually make things
faster behind you to do that
like to trick you into Jesus so wait oh
dude that c4 I don't know how I don't
know how I don't know how it didn't kill
me wow did you I officially have gone
past my last time playing that was the
bear that killed me oh look remote
explosive damage did it carve him
alright
[Music]
okay things are going well that was nuts
what next you got time for like another
quest I'd say so you have ten and a half
minutes left you survive for that long
we pick up on this save file next week
this is really hard to take have you no
one to fall zhenya there's no way I
could do it no like should I just go
make your way down toward it
yeah should I just like go down along
this path I'm sure there's a couple
things here yeah up on this hill maybe
yeah this is probably an outpost let's
check that out
yeah like people are saying I think the
bear got all the shrapnel I think that's
you use him as a big thick bear hide
that was dude II was so making noise at
first no not even a pitter-pat of pause
oh check out back and get my bow and
arrow I should yeah yeah Bob Jones will
the farther into a game we get we'll
start doing some more daring things yeah
we could start throwing challenges in
like only use your fists yeah we won't
do that one but
oh my god I had a heart attack
yeah the second one of the day that's
the thing about this how can I get this
one yeah I can ooh does that act is that
better oh it's got the red dot or no is
it even better just yeah it's better now
I have arrows it's the most garish bow
looks like a nerf bow yeah
[Music]
now we do that I'm so nervous about you
we have like nine minutes okay so I'm so
nervous but you're just going through
the woods on foot
yeah no you're almost at the end of the
first episode I like how I tried to
argued earlier when I was trying to
argue that the wrongest rated your back
Cougars
clawing at me it's a lovely day
there's some mortar Oh what's he doing
nothing
check kill this guy
gonna kill us you know these roads are
packed of people yeah he's being
annoying
a few dudes heavy is it nice uh yeah
it's gonna say let's blow up if they're
on fire oh wait you should slip on fire
that'll keep the Cougar away everything
that could explode here has exploded
right car yeah
all right
oK you've got a little bit ammo
experience challenge perk points alright
yeah how about how about you try to take
one more outpost or do one more
objective before the end of the hour
okay
oh what's in that bag anything
sorry I thought I heard some thing I
mean I don't know where in a poster that
no yeah I mean like yeah something in
general I mean I haven't feeling there
something up here it was just me
you got the parachute now so jumping off
a cliff and pulling the string is like a
viable escape action option yeah it
depends on the steepness of the cliff
there's some APIs on there
that's another thing his gang run over
by oh cool I didn't take this this is an
outpost is it alright this is a good
closer all right you survived this
you've survived the first episode
Jesus you're really going for those
headshots you imagine be that guy and
having these by your head blows a barrel
they're just mental no love barrels no
it's just two guys Oh is there a prepper
stash up here on YouTube
hey you want to pit oh [ __ ] oh my god
I'm shot nice what about as well as it
could she's dead are you sure though hey
little boy you want to pick all right
all right I think that was it you got
five minutes
you did that faster than I thought you
might same well if I die doing this
would not be just ridiculous yeah
anything oh there's a prepper stash
around here oh yeah where was the thing
I don't know if that'd be a fun way to
it's right near the bed
oh yeah you just read their zip lines
actually do that yeah you're going down
to the farm though I think you already
liberated this farm wait oh so it's
right there well nevermind you did not
ride the zip lines that seems easy
enough half hope ugh on the Eagle
doesn't come oh [ __ ]
I just jinx it Oh ambience oh my god no
way
oh my god no don't you had four minutes
left oh my god did you miss the platform
I don't know how that happened
you just broke every bone in your body
ah man well there you go
how long was that that was 57 minutes
and 10 seconds that you survived we
should record that for the next episode
I'm gonna stop that timer yeah okay uh
it's probably a good time to end it then
you kind of got right to the end of the
episode how did that happen two and a
half minutes how did that happen you're
shooting at him and then I think he
disrupted your dismount and you just
fell I don't know like it should have
auto dis you want to explore what
happened while we have a couple minutes
like I'm trying to I think you just know
I think you he attacked you and you've
let go of the zipline too early so
instead of I didn't let go [ __ ] though
he attacked you and I think if they
somehow like watch
so he was right here I shot at oh no so
oh I'm supposed to yeah you didn't
connect to the map I was to the next one
I didn't know that and I I think you
might have died anyway even if he was oh
all right
we're on to doom next episode ah should
I start for a few yeah we I don't know
if you know we have time we technically
have two minutes because that wasn't the
hour yeah I guess we could do two
minutes we're gonna start on your
profile okay I'll start y'all will start
with you just keep in mind it was 57
minutes in 20 seconds 20 seconds two
minutes and 10 seconds left I start this
what have what do people think should I
start this with the minute we have I
don't even know if we'll honestly just
yeah it'll take two minutes to get the
game going just boot up the game how
about how about and pause it why not I
mean I think I think it's literally by
the time we get there it'll be an hour
all right so the question we set out
with was could we beat Far Cry 5 in one
life yeah Bob Jones regardless if I
don't get there we will we will make
sure we get through intros and whatnot
before we go live anyway but I might as
well technically have a minute so and I
would very much like to think I'm not
gonna die right away
mmm no you should literally discovery up
a list while it's loading
so that trip time will be 57 minutes and
20 seconds
doom is up next for next week on
ultraviolence
um could give a little teaser yeah I
mean I don't even think you can work
okay doom campaign game slot one do you
mind if I overwrite this yeah go for it
that's you wait no I'll just a new
thought yeah hurt me plenty on
ultraviolence this is the highest
available difficulty I'll just start so
we have the save file and we can get
everybody for next week next week will
be do not work right
you should go pretty long I'm Bob Jones
we could list the cause of death as well
I don't know if that would require too
much redesigning so here's actually kind
of layout of the shows what you can
expect every week so next week what
we'll do is I'll cut a highlight reel of
last week's episode we'll run that
before we start doom 6 minutes it's what
this guy's giving me on 6 minutes
resident 4 will be we don't we honestly
don't know when these oh sorry we don't
know when these will happen because it
could be I mean it could have been today
honestly if we died enough in these
games it might be three months from now
we honestly have no idea it'll be sooner
than three months but resi before will
be very interesting because it's dynamic
difficulty explore prep first a she says
yeah this is ultra violence I'll kill
these guys pretty good another week a
mistake kill yeah wow this is sensitive
or maybe it's just the 4k I'm not used
to that makes sense all right sweet I'm
a handgun I would very much like to play
for one hour that kind of defeats the
rules we just sent over the show yeah
it's this is also to be treated as like
a kind of like a vods let's play series
in a sense so strict one hour and so far
if you are watching this
I'll watch this thing get bad the way if
you're watching this like as a vada on
YouTube and like after that's live then
yeah welcome one our second game like
you starting the video you might not
know have known that we would be playing
doom today god damn it why should we
call there yeah I think that's an
autosave I believe yeah let's get amped
get and for next week
doom I promise to not should I play doom
at all and the interim or I guess that's
up to us
oh you mean train yeah I mean I got
electroplated I played enough to him I
don't know I'll find out I will let
people know publicly if I play Doom yeah
people mentioned Skyrim that'd be fun I
know Jake and John Luke were uh that was
an idea they had for Skyrim this game we
so Rob and I when we were kind of tests
morphing what the show would be Doom was
one of the games we tried well if you
saw the teaser video on Monday then you
saw some doom footage and just a long
ridge oh I thought no no I won't
memorize it I just like it as far as
getting the muscle memory for the game I
might play a little bit yeah see this
guy gets the grave hopper spirit doing
guy alright sweet that's uh let's call
it yep
want to do one of these to pick I'm
doing this because I'm you would have to
try very hard to die here and I guess I
just got hit okay okay alright Auto Save
is gonna tell me huh get the shotgun yes
just get it well I meant like should I
train the save it for next week alright
cool
and here we are this game is we picked
this game specifically because it
literally is designed to keep you moving
alright let's we'll cut it there there
pause it little list maybe go to that go
to our camera I guess okay I'm not gonna
do it do we have can you bring up lower
thirds or no no no yeah nevermind okay
cool thanks everybody for joining
this thursday afternoon or thursday
morning if you're in Australia Thursday
night if you're in the UK we this is
first episode of grave hopper it's gonna
be a livestream show but if you came in
a little later or had to join a little
later this is gonna be up on YouTube
pretty much right after the show right
yeah pretty much you're gonna do
highlights and we do that so do that
yeah just again clarify like so next
week we're gonna start the show with a
little intro and we're gonna run maybe
like a minute to minute highlights of
this episode so the previous week always
and then we get right into where we left
off which it'll be doomed yep so we are
first we are the first of the nine games
we have written down but as always these
are you can see a little asterisk these
are subject to change some are newer Far
Cry 5 included some are older doom halo
especially Dark Souls remastered Last of
Us remastered on the grounded mode that
will be fun but you can see which we're
alternating who will be playing but yeah
Thursday every Thursday at 2 p.m.
provided we're both here in town which
will almost always be the case always we
will be playing every Thursday at 2 p.m.
Pacific mm-hmm we're picking up with
doom next week doom with perma deaths on
ultraviolence difficulty thanks everyone
thanks guys that I have a great rest the
week good bye
[Music]